for the very first time some of Megan
Marvel's closest friends are giving us
an inside look at the life of the
Dutchess of Sussex in a CBS News special
they talk about why she is so ready for
motherhood
[Music]
Archie's here and it's clear Three's
Company it's just gonna be so much love
for that baby Daniel Martin is one of
Megan's closest friends so is actor
Janina gavankar to have the the royal
family bring a child of color into the
world it's pretty awesome there are
still a lot of us who didn't even grow
up with dolls that look like us
Megan and I have talked about her being
a mother for over a decade she's always
wanted to be a mom uh she yeah she's
gonna be such a good mother I think
she'll be very low-maintenance I I think
that she will be very hands-on
will she be out there making her own
baby photo I totally see her making her
food yeah I was kidding yeah no she's
yeah she loves to cook and as for Harry
he's so good with kids even when they
were doing the family portrait after the
wedding with everybody he was on the
floor just playing with the kids and
that's when I knew him like he's gonna
be the coolest dad yet with all the joy
Megan and Harry have been blessed with
there have been some ugly challenges
headlines and speculations painting her
as demanding dubbed Duchess difficult
you hear these stories and there's no
truth to them your Excellencies prime
minister but Megan her friends know is
fully confident in who she is and steers
clear of the rumor mill she doesn't read
the bad or the good because she knows
the metrics that you have for your own
life cannot be based on a headline what
are the tears about for you I think cuz
I know her so well
[Music]
she doesn't deserve all this negative
press through it all Harry has been by
her side she is with her soul mates the
two of them together very powerful and
making royal history a newly-minted
tradition that Archie a distant seventh
in line for the throne is now poised to
carry on this is a dawn of a new
generation that their child is going to
represent what the world is now and you
can see our special Megan and Harry plus
one that's tonight at 8:00 7:00 central
right here on CBS I know when you think
about a lot has happened to her in a
year she got married she moved and she
had a baby all three of life's stressor
and many years she did it one year we
are cheering you on Megan Marco Prince
Harry - and little Archie you're
watching CBS this morning
[Music]